Chloe and Georgia says should debt be a
factor when breaking up with a
significant other do you wait it out
while they clean up their debt I don't
want to get married to someone if I'm
going to have to turn around and pay off
their debt they shouldn't get married
just by that question as far as I'm
concerned
nobody should marry you nope because
everybody's gonna bring something a
whole bunch of stuff I don't like that
question
I don't like data to dove the question
how about that that's it I mean yeah
you're because what you're saying Chloe
is is that debt and you having to pay
off someone else's debt is more
important than who you're choosing to
spend your life with and more important
than that person it's kind of like I had
a guy a lady called me one time she said
my boyfriend am I gonna marry be my
fiance wants a prenup and I said for
what he has a classic car oh gosh so
don't marry him no absolutely not
he's choosing a stinking car over you
already and burn the car down it's worth
18 months in jail for a few rounds into
it but yeah yeah it's kind of that it's
that kind of same spirit here Chloe
you're choosing your no one is worth it
to you mmm to pay off their debt and
that's not a good place to be Chloe now
when when you join in marriage you're
agreeing before your friends and your
community and whatever government you
happen to be same before God whoever
you're getting married in front of I'm
taking them and I'm taking everything
they're bringing with me and we're going
to work on whatever that is together and
stuff will emerge over 10 years and 20
you're taking it together and if you go
in with that attitude of I I just yeah
yeah no so let me back up and give you a
little bit of a little bit of Grayson
let's ask it a different way let's
pretend you hadn't asked it the way you
asked it which was a wee bit revealing
but aside from that
let's pretend you just said the first
part should Det be a factor when
breaking up with a significant other my
answer has always been no you know the
rare what would be a factor is their
unwillingness to address it the spirit
of it right now
I'm gonna stay in debt the rest of my
life oh I hate that then you're not a
match or I'm not gonna hear your
concerns there imitating from your heart
about how you hate that yeah and I'm not
gonna I don't care what you have to say
about things I'm that's okay I'm always
gonna have debt and you yeah and if you
don't like that forget it well I'd
forget it there you know but if
somebody's got $100,000 in debt and you
know everything else in the relationship
is right including the fact that you're
saying when we get married together
we're going to address this and they're
already starting to address it we're
gonna get it paid off we're going to go
gazelle in tents we're gonna get this
knocked out then that's marriage
material
mmm Dave Ramsey's kids were not told to
pick a spouse based on whether they had
debt or not you just caused the wrecks
in middle America more they didn't I
didn't yeah but I did say you know don't
marry somebody that it has a different
value system than you have I love it
which is don't you know you know in a
different value system is somebody's
gonna be irresponsible with money mm-hm
well they're not gonna listen to your
heart I had a friend of mine whose
daughter guy came to him you know young
man came and asked for his dad that her
dad's permission to marry her and he
said no cuz you don't work I've never
seen you keep a job hmm because
everything else about you I like but you
don't work he should be in the dad Hall
of Fame yeah and you know what what
happened was this he said I love you and
I'll teach you how to work hmm and and
if you work hard for a year and you'll
stay on the job and you'll act like
you're starting to develop that muscle
of work ethic then you can earn my
daughter's hand mm-hmm he didn't say
yeah you don't have enough money he
didn't say you know it wasn't a value to
him he said as a character issue
you know kids lazy
and he's like you know young man was
lazy he said you know yeah that's dad
Hall of Fame stuff because what he did
was the guy ended up marrying his
daughter as he did you know he didn't
have a model in his life and this man
the new father-in-law
to be came alongside him and loved it
and walked with him and coached him and
loved him and any married his daughter
but he's and he taught he brought of
character quality to him that wasn't
there and boy he got his attention
that's a no huh you don't like to work I
love it good for him kid by fell out of
his chair you think yeah yeah well my
father not told me I don't say that on
the air
no don't Texas hunter he put me on
notices but I'll say he's good and
rightfully so he's a great man